this is the love God and what do you
have there
you know I know that as I descended into
madness with the sweat around I've made
a lot of mistakes but this time this
time I think I can make up for it
completely how's this so I have combined
waffles basically are op across with
waddles that I've been you know rubbing
against my cheek constantly and Snoopy
together at last I present to you
snapples and look they're so happy
together I even use sparkly duct tape
that is so Mabel it's funny cuz it's a
sin against nature
anywho okay uh so this is you're so
excited to put that together too it's
like do you have like duct tape and
another plushie like the second you saw
they with the bacon the goat you're just
like yeah you cannot deny the world its
snapples
so uh this is an episode where Robbie is
back um yeah I didn't go anywhere oh
wait I guess in many respects people
have been calling this the Christmas but
so does it technically I think it's the
only one coming out around Christmas
time so nothing says Christmas episode
like Cemetery yeah Valentine's Day yeah
this blows Cemetery is supposed to be
place of fun not depressing there's some
line like yeah so it clearly not
Christmas happens I don't think they're
gonna do a Christmas episode it'd be
amazing if they did cuz I love Christmas
but it it's more it makes more sense to
do a Halloween episode honestly so I
figure that uh but you have all of
Wendy's friends are back together
hanging out and they see Robbie is in a
grave sulking that him and Wendy still
broke out so Mabel being Mabel wants to
set him up and get him with another
person and
like the vulture trying to eat him yeah
uh trisys said I wasn't eat Tambor's was
that it something like that the girls
over there yeah the purple hair it's
always on the phone they don't get along
but then this artist called the love God
pops up which is a shame because I
really would have preferred woodgrain on
everything like if I'm gonna listen to a
bale and what gray mound everything
would have been mine I like scarves
indoors you know because this sar big
hipster event comes along to get all
these kids together and he's one of them
but it turns out he literally is a love
God he's kind of like a cupid and he has
his own little potion so Mabel steals a
few gives it to the two of them they
fall in love
splitting up the group somehow very
bizarrely and they try to fix it back
but then they find out Robbie and her
are happy so let's just leave it and the
group gets back together too and we see
Robbie's parents who are a million whole
my crown painting the Ralphie it
explains everything because he's still
rebelling against what is a dark goth
kind of like set up with the whole
funeral home yeah it's actually some
parents not really friendly yeah it's
actually even more God because they work
in such a gothic place but they're so
happy and cheerful a be like to happy
they're like I wonder if somebody died
like they're just a total denial of
anything negative maybe I loved the
progression of pictures it shows rallies
uh progression into teenage head it
literally was like a time-lapse of
watching you go around my idea like you
know obviously like it even right down
to the hair parted in the middle and the
way the picnics right from ye went to my
head you know that a to really was me as
a teen uh the room I room looked exactly
we saw like the Burton corner and stuff
in the alwah no interview no event that
was definite welcome to dog walkers
pretentiously oh it was so pretty I'm
not standing by I'm not like no you just
didn't understand each other it's like
no I was just I was just like Ravi I was
a little artistic freak I was just like
oh I told you to my beautiful whites
affair
neighborhood maybe that's why I hate the
character reminds me reminds me you too
it is just the name though maybe oh the
fact that he's an ask but go so um yeah
the one one thing I noticed I'll read
the whole thing at the end here but one
thing I noticed that mushroom cloud the
spray-paint mushroom cloud comes back
against in his room interesting it looks
like all the young characters have four
fingers which I don't get cuz the TNA
abs like maybe it's easier to draw
because they're younger in there yeah I
don't quite use all four larger
characters it's easier to put five
fingers on them but if you got a smaller
character you have to draw it's like
four little fingers at all right uh one
of the messages here at the player at
the fair I always see them standing
there dressed in black they're on my
lawn but when I turn my head they're
gone
so I I don't know what that is is that
that's a that's a weird one um and then
the actual ending one or oh honey this
is the ending one uh oh
one arriving raceboys right now that's a
bit dang I thought there's another one
that I know there's another one
uh oh when using a code it says Goten
pig and also I can't uh referencing the
balloon is it meanness yet yes how can
you look away in my opinion this was a
pest and okay episode until we got to
that ending with the balloon I love the
way it just is coming down like that
moon out of Majora's Mask like mom and I
do I love the uh maybe it's cuz we're
older now but I really love the cracks
at like the teenagers and stuff like
that I've learned to embrace the madness
and kind of appreciate what awful people
they are cuz they're all terrible
yeah well it's one of those things to
where it's like that poor other guy that
keeps trying to keep the group together
and you know there's smacking around
like a pinata wow what a great use of
Thompson yessuh Tom's is becoming one of
my favorite uh it probably really
likable funny character in that group
cuz he's so sad and put that
um and I also what what the hell is that
line again just like you know he's gonna
eat kids we're kids maybe we should stop
making everything terrible popular or
something like that oh no it was like
this is punishment from the heavens yeah
for like for our bad for this is live
from the heavens for having a bad taste
in everything that was it really
teenagers all suck unless you're our
fans in which case you're awesome yeah
thank you oh but no honest leave anyone
younger than us this is a hellacious
bands in which case you know but again
it's one of those things where it's like
I it's okay cuz like I said it's like I
I was Robbie I was that dumbass teenager
I was you know had all the honestly ins
this is redemption form a bit though
because now that he's not such a raging
douchebag maybe you'll like the
character a little more he was still
pretty annoying you know but I honestly
I will say this
seeing his backstory and how it just
explained everything in like three shots
yeah really how does a visual yeah you
meet his parents you walk down the
hallway and then you're into his room
and I'm like wow this just explained the
whole character in about 60 seconds I
love LA I love shows or movies that can
explain something without dialogue and
can do it visually because it is a
visual medium Roger red uh yeah that's
what you're thinking of yeah Azim with
Eddie valiance desk where it goes
through his whole backstory with the
saxophone playing and then he wakes up
drunk like yeah I mean it's like we live
in a like movies right now it's like are
so visual they're so visually
interesting uh you know and even chose
to buy worlds on the Christopher Nolan
age where it requires reams and reams of
dialogue yeah like we seem to be like
it's not just Nolan I mean is like we
pick on him like he's kind of like the
crowning achievement of it buddies like
he's the poster child which is what it
yeah but at the same time it's like so I
really like it when somebody does then
they do like or the opening rear rear
window with it shows through his picture
all that's happened to him uh and I love
any show or movie that can do that so
when that's still being done uh I love
when they can't incorporate that in um
but yeah like I say it wasn't till maybe
the N where am i okay now really
laughing again into it everything else I
was like chuckle here er there um is the
early stuff from a graveyard oh yeah
a lot of guys like says I like to do
Dipper fill me I was being dramatic I
like the snow with dipper trying to fit
in to the group um I like because it
didn't feel too forest like in I feel
like in the first season like me that
would be the focus of the episode
instead more like a side thing I think
it's much more fitting as a side falling
I like the moral to of like you miss in
people's love lives it's gonna mess
things up did that she doesn't set them
back I wasn't here about this is one
weird dipper was actually correct over
Mabel for a change it because he's like
we have a balance here you're gonna mess
up this balance and that's why I'm back
and forth sometime yeah but yeah but
like I mean in the end it all works out
but like he was right like you and she
realizes like you know the more we mess
around with this the worse it's gonna
get you know it's just why I was almost
wonder I feel smart not to break them up
cuz I'm like but they were still forced
under you know they're still under an
illusion or something but maybe that's
like the 'dealing maybe now they're not
or something I don't know but is it is
it a delusion I mean if they both
believe it and while I'm happy wine on
top of that like you said something bad
you damn Christmas argument where you
were just like you know no if you don't
have what I deems right for you then
you're unhappy yeah that one's actually
why Sam word for word you nailed it you
totally got it you told everybody to go
outside because you deem it correct no
and then I went outside and I was scarce
there were people who wanted to talk to
me um nope I was guessing but the idea
about them like not going back to it's
like you said they messed up enough so
it's like why interfere even more uh
which I think there's kind of valuable
lessons like do if you've done like
there is a responsibility if you messed
up something fiddling I've it's probably
gonna make it even worse here's the
thing they were happy and they seemed
legitimately happy
what was the friends problem nothing
they were being petty little whiny
bitches about it because they had their
alike really like those two ended up
being legitimately happy and he's like
I'm happy you know I've gotten over the
friends were just being stupid
there's
whoa I kind of secretly liked your
buzzers oh that's just like dating my ex
like it's petty jealousy yeah okay and
it works out anyway so yeah I actually
made that it's kind of a good lesson for
like teenagers to just like half of what
you know half is legit half is
of the drama that you're going through
and half is what JIT though yeah that
guy's like it's not but half it's like
ya know your that's just being a
teenager um yeah I mean that's part of
it too it's like dude they're gonna it's
gonna work out I mean it's like if
something is really important really
meaningful and you know your true colors
will shine through with their true
colors bada-bing
um so it's still good it's not a bad
episode by any means um yeah though I
guess I think was mostly just it had a
good start I had a good finish and the
middle is ain't like okay uh so yeah um
taking away samples kill me you're such
a cute sin against nature
damn stub dance I said dance bye